[Music]
my first guess is of course an Emmy
award-winning comedian who was starred
in the HBO series Curb Your Enthusiasm
she's been in many films including the
greatest movie of all time
Pootie Tang I love saying Pootie Tang
it's the greatest title of a film ever
it's a great movie but the greatest
title ever Pootie Tang the only regret
is they never said in the Oscar for best
film goes to pujita what's so great it's
fine no matter where out where I'm at
you know if I'm doing the show it could
be anywhere I mean no matter what the
age of the audience right somebody else
out Pootie Tang yeah and whenever
somebody goes
I love Pootie Tang you're basically
telling me you smoke weed yes I think
you called it no no not me
high-fiber diet for me you got so much
to talk about first of all I want to get
your opinion on this Newsweek cover came
out this week and it is getting so much
attention and people are saying they
pretty much have got at this the first
gay president Barack Obama and I'm just
curious of course it's been a very
controversial color not sure how the
president feels about it how do you what
do you think about this it's so junior
high you know it's like I mean really I
mean just because you say you're for gay
marriage that doesn't make you gay you
know it's like you know it's like oh you
like to quality you're so gay you know
it's almost it's like that and and yeah
if they want to really say like the the
first gay president you know he should
have been like in drag or something you
know they have made of people have come
down this he's a gay angel
with crazy superpowers I mean you think
you think it'd be better if they put him
in drag or something it's just silly
I mean you know the president said hey
I'm for equality he didn't say you know
I'm gonna go be on RuPaul's Drag Race
you know he did come out with that
announcement later yeah it's gonna make
the rounds yeah I got to ask you about
of course crazy stuff coming on Wall
Street JP Morgan a major JPMorgan
executive stepped down people are
resigning at JP more than they think
there's gonna be more and more people
stepping down because of this because of
this crisis they lost how much money who
billion billion dollars they lost two
billion dollars right and that they're
now staying on Friday and then Sunday
they announced that the guy you know
responsible was stepping down I'm like
we didn't even need that announcement
because if you lose two billion dollars
don't show up at work
[Laughter]
anybody see the game
[Laughter]
calls for the two billion yeah billion
dollars you just don't show up come on
man yeah what about the I have to get
your take on the The Secret Service
scandal that of course involving
prostitutes Secret Service agents hiring
prostitutes did you call this story yeah
now it's this is just to me the story
but what I wanted to see was witness
Secret Service that when those guys
showed up at home and they're facing
their wives that's the story right there
right you know positions and you walk in
and your wife is just sitting there just
waiting for you home early huh what's he
gonna say at that point Oh baby it was
crazy uh you know it was these crazy
hookers were
ah yeah I was crazy it was crazy so
talking about some time off now and it
was over what one guy was arguing over
forty seven dollar bill like that you
know right that was forty seven dollars
I mean have you seen a beautiful women
in Colombia
I mean forty seven dollars is not that I
would even tipped you know just come up
with the money that's just I don't know
yeah it bugs you I can tell bugs you
it's City and the thing that's getting
you most is the price if you don't know
a bargain you you should be protecting
the president